[موسيقى]
زوجان من مجموعتك يتقابلان مع
بعضهما البعض ، تحاول أن تكون أسرع من
الأخرى التي نطاردها
[موسيقى]
تحصل على القليل من الأدرينالين ، إنها
ليست آمنة تمامًا ، لذا عليك فقط
اعتني بنفسك وأنت تعلم أنك تتعامل مع
أنبوب كبير يمكن أن يسحبك حقًا ،
فلديك خوف كبير من أن هذه الطائرة الورقية
ستخرجني من العربة التي تجرها الدواب ،
وسأجرجر على الأرض
[موسيقى]
تريد تجربتها و  تأكد من حصولك على
مساحة مسطحة حقًا لا تحتوي على الكثير من
الصخور ، إذا كانت هناك صخور تريد أن
تعرف مكانها ، فما عليك سوى زيادة
سرعتك ويمكنك حقًا أن تكون
أسرع ما لدي هو حوالي 74
كيلومترًا في الساعة
خاصةً عندما  إنك على بعد بوصتين فقط
من الأرض على عربة ذات ثلاث عجلات ،
إنه لأمر مدهش تمامًا
[موسيقى]
إذا كان لديك الحق في الفوز
بالمشهد المناسب والأصدقاء المناسبين حول
ما يمكنك أن تطلبه أكثر من
[موسيقى]